Mike pillow is now calling Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis disgusting
DeSantis is the Trojan Horse we thought
he was I just want to put that out there
how disgusting he is the Civil War
within the Republican Party between Maga
and non-maga is only growing there was
the idea from some that this wasn't
going to become a big conflict that this
was going to be a nice clean primary
DeSantis hasn't even announced that he's
running for president yet and Mike
pillow Steve Bannon Don Jr and of course
Donald Trump himself are going after
DeSantis daily this is only going to get
worse and I expect this to be the
ugliest Republican primary certainly in
the last 20 years